budgets are ultimately about taxing and
spending so let's have a look at both of
those two things starting with taxing
let's look at the tax burden it's the
essentially the amount that we are all
paying in tax as a percentage of
national income and if you go back this
is the entire post-war period here you
can see it bounces around
but just look it is expected to go up
and last time around it was expected to
go up quite a bit this time it's
expected to go up a lot look at this red
line over here going up to the highest
level that we've seen since the 1940s
and according to the resolution
foundation you're talking about that
being the equivalent of an extra 3 000
pounds per household in taxes so we are
all paying more tax but in return for
that we are getting more in the way of
spending there was a spending review as
well wasn't there and let's compare this
spending review with previous spending
reviews so you can see the era of gordon
brown spending rather a lot under labor
you've got that period of austerity
there the coalition government and then
you've got these later spending rounds
those two kind of one-year ones we had
previously and then this one still in
positive territory so rising rather than
falling but a little bit less than in
previous years that does raise a
question though austerity it might be
over to in some senses but has it been
undone have we kind of changed the
balance when it comes to different
governments uh different parts of the
government and here you can see well
it's a bit of a mixed story the further
these bars are across this way the
bigger their budgets are compared with
2009-10 so basically pre-austerity what
you can probably see is overall they're
up that's the first bar the health
system so department of health and
social care up enormously by about 42
education up as well but other
departments that yellow bar though if
you exclude health they're down they're
down compared with where they were
before austerity uh hm revenue and
customs ministry of defense ministry of
justice all down quite considerably so
austerity not undone although it is
starting to get uh undone numbers are
starting to go up but how about for the
rest of us how about for you know the
pound in our pocket if you have a look
at real earnings which is perhaps the
best measure of just how wealthy uh
we're getting uh each year it was going
up before the financial crisis people
thought it would carry on going up and
we'd get better off going up to about 30
pounds an hour in real terms so adjust
it for inflation but we all know what
happened next look it basically
flatlined and the latest forecasts from
the obr the office budget
responsibilities suggest it's going to
carry on flatline look look at that red
line that's basically where it continues
actually people getting a bit worse off
in the next few years and by 2026 the
end of this forecast horizon it suggests
we are going to have lower real wages
than going all the way back to 2008.